préserver ses intérêts chouchoutez des
clients qui participent directement ou
pas à de nombreux conflits de par le
monde en matière de vente d'armes la
position du gouvernement français est
clair quitte à déclarer la guerre à des
membres du parlement
parmi eux deux députés jacques maire de
la république en marche et michèle
tabarot du groupe l'est républicain
à l'origine de cette panique au coeur de
l'exécutif un rapport parlementaire sur
un contrôle plus strict et démocratique
des exportations d'armements en d'autres
termes à qui sont destinés les armes
fabriquées par la france et surtout à
quelle fin parmi les 35 propositions du
rapport une inédite la création d'une
commission parlementaire chargée de
contrôler les exportations d'armements
une proposition très vite torpillée par
les services de matignon sentant la
menace se précisait selon une note du
secrétariat général de la défense et de
la sécurité nationale la sgdn organisme
indépendant des services du premier
ministre une telle proposition porterait
atteinte aux intérêts et aux engagements
de la france sous couvert d'un objectif
d'une plus grande transparence et d'un
meilleur dialogue entre les pouvoirs
exécutif et législatif
l'objectif sont bien deux contre un de
la politique du gouvernement en matière
d'exportations en renforçant le contrôle
parlementaire
un tel contrôle de l'action de
l'exécutif risquerait de nuire à la
crédibilité des engagements de la france
et à sa capacité à exporter une note de
quatre pages classé confidentiel défense
détaillé par nos confrères de 10 close
où l'exécutif tente tant bien que mal de
justifier sa politique jouant tantôt la
carte du secret défense tantôt celle des
intérêts nationaux
en d'autres termes étouffer cette libye
parlementaire visant à exiger une trop
grande transparence sur les ventes
d'armes en avril 2019 le mediadisk laws
avait déjà pointé du doigt les
agissements de la france en matière de
vente d'armes notamment dans le cadre du
conflit au yémen qui a fait au bas mot
plus de cent mille morts depuis 2014
deux de nos confrères publié une enquête
intitulée made in france
ou comment la france participe
indirectement à la guerre au yémen en
vendant ses armes à l'arabie saoudite et
aux émirats arabes unis une enquête
gênante qui avait valu aux deux
journalistes de disclose geoffrey lee
lee et mathias des stalles à l'origine
de ces révélations
un petit passage par la case bureaux de
la direction générale du renseignement
intérieur c'était le 14 mai 2010 neuf
dans le cadre d'une enquête préliminaire
pour je cite compromission du secret de
la défense nationale
car c'est bien là la question suivante
qui est au coeur de toutes ces
préoccupations où la france participe
tel ne serait ce qu'un directement à des
crimes de guerre commis en libye ou
encore au yémen
rien que pour le yémen l'état français a
livré pour 1,3 milliard d'euros
d'armement à l'arabie saoudite un acteur
majeur de ce conflit le ministère des
armées assure pourtant que les armes
vendues leçon à des fins défensives
nous n'avons jamais prétendu qu'aucune
arme française n'était utilisée au yémen
mais nous n'avons aujourd'hui aucune
preuve qui attesterait que des armes de
fabrication français sont utilisés à
dessein contre des populations civiles
en mars dernier un classement de
l'institut sipri établissait que la
france était le troisième plus gros
exportateur d'armes au monde avec plus
de 7% de part de marché rien qu'en 2018
elle avait vendu pour 9,1 milliards
d'euros d'armement un marché juteux qui
semble préférable de protéger quitte à
détourner le regard sur l' usage des
armes et protéger l'anonymat des riches
et puissants clients de l'hexagone car
cette volonté de plus grande
transparence sur l'identité des
acheteurs du rapport parlementaire
l'exécutif souhaite la voir disparaître
entre les considérations éthiques de la
protection d'un marché très rémunérateur
matignon semble avoir choisi son camp
quitte à ce que les vélleités de
démocratie du parlement en la matière
elle ne fasse pas long feu